de jeux vidéo blizzard d'éditrice du
célèbre warcraft dont le siège européen
est basé à versailles a décidé
d'investir la cité royale pour le
lancement de la nouvelle extension d'une
autre de ses licences phares starcraft
l'événement se déroulait hier soir lundi
il a été retransmis dans le monde entier
avant de découvrir les images de les
images de ce show je vous propose de
voir ou de revoir bien sûr pour les
passionnés le teaser le clip qui a été
réalisée à l'occasion la ville de
versailles mise en scène est dans une
dans un teaser dans un petit film digne
d'une superproduction américaine
regarder
vidéo starcraft 2 qui a donc été lancée
à versailles à versailles comme vous ne
l'avez sans doute jamais vu auparavant
dans le petit film qui a été réalisé par
cette société blizzard
c'était au palais des congrès de
versailles le lancement de ce jeu vidéo
lundi soir quatre heures de spectacle
avec des champions du monde de la
discipline un vrai spectacle
le reportage de claire cambier et de
ledit moine ni le froid ni la pluie
n'aurait pu décourager ses fans de jeux
vidéo
hier à versailles ont fêté le lancement
de the heart of the swarm la dernière
extension du jeu vidéo starcraft 2 créé
par la société blizzard
pourquoi versailles car c'est ici que
l'entreprise a installé son siège
européen et pour ses joueurs c'était
l'événement à ne pas manquer là on
attend depuis une heure une heure et
demie quelque chose comme ça mais c'est
surtout les conditions il fait super
froid donc c'est un peu dur le premier
jeu je l'attendais depuis dix ans à peu
près là bas je suis obligé d'être là
pour la 2eme quoi donc
g j'ai pris des heures en moins sur mon
taf mais bon des fans prêtes à tout pour
assister à ce lancement planétaire
une promotion impressionnante et une
stratégie marketing au point les fans
parfois maquiller à l'effigié des
personnages de starcraft sont rentrés
dans le jeu
entre deux photos avec les héros on
n'oublie pas de passer par la case
souvenir c'est juste le petit plus si
fragon l'oubliera pas et il n'est pas
prêt d'oublier sa soirée car dans la
salle il y avait des stars en chair et
en os des joueurs professionnels comme
stefano le jeune français qui n'a pas
hésité à poser avec ses admirateurs en
tout quatre joueurs prêts à s'affronter
toute la soirée sur scène à ce jeu de
stratégie sur pc
une guerre sans merci sur une autre
galaxie entre les tehran les protos et
les zergs
attention le show commence dans un
anglais presque parfait
car cet événement mondial était
retranscrit en live sur internet
le show de versailles suivez ceux de
l'australie et de la corée du sud avant
de donner le relais aux états unis